hello everybody I am officially back
from comic-con and I have the swag to
prove it
if you've been following me on Facebook
you've seen me with this in action
my Assassin's Creed 3 tomahawk I won
about seven of these well not one I
waited in line and saw a movie seven
times to get seven of these don't judge
me I also got this Hello Kitty rainbow
tiara thingy that I found on the street
vendor some poor guy was handing
Mountain I chopped them with my accent
oh I also have this master the universe
noisemaker here
ah that I found on the floor or not on
the floor on the trade show floor but I
finally just sing I also have this
incredibly awesome Assassin's Creed
Revelations
playing card deck that I found or one
from trivia from the assassin creed
booth but anyway that's enough of that
anyway the main point is oh no wait I
forgot one more thing I won this tie
this absolutely awesome hitman
absolution ties
really it's a gorgeous tie I just had to
wear it which explains why I'm dressed
up so nicely anyway I won this because I
completed the challenge this plus a tie
clip you can't see the chocolate but
I've got it under there now anyway I won
that for completing the hitman
absolution pregame challenge they had
all available at their booth the Square
Enix booth I believe anyway
totally besides the point the point is
I'm back and I'm ready to make videos
for you guys again
the mere fact that people actually came
up to me and recognized me in like we're
excited to meet me was amazing and
humbling actually you think it boost up
my ego but actually it made me feel like
wow what I'm doing is actually having
some sort of an impact on people so I
better get to work which is why I set up
this mini studio here to try to get a
better you know production quality on my
V log so they're not just something off
my webcam that I'm doing it like desk
and a ratty old shirt I want to have
quality entertainment calling theater
cameras
anyway now that that's out of the way
what I mean to say is I want this
channel to be more appealing I want this
challenge channel to be more than just
Let's Plays I want this channel to
really be something that helps out in
the gaming community which is why I'm
going to do more of these V logs
regularly in my semi-professional ratty
little studio was you know actually nice
studio lights and whatnot but I'm
actually trying to put something into it
so that you guys can have more I don't
know when I'm going to update I'm still
working out the details but the fact of
the matter is I want to do more for you
guys if you guys are going to support me
then I sure as hell better be ready to
give back so expect more of these be
logged with updates on game reviews game
news basically anything gaming related
that I want to talk about or I think you
should know about you're going to hear
about and I know this is so
professionally waiting my tomahawk
around but either way get ready for more
content I am so amazed at the progress
we've had in such a short amount of time
in the growth of the channel is already
starting to explode I we just hit 2000
before I left for comic-con and now
we're almost at 3,000 how crazy is that
like I can't even believe it uh thank
you guys so much for enjoying my content
and sharing it with your friends and
everyone you know and just making this
channel into something bigger and better
than I had ever hoped and I made a
promise to myself because of the fact
that even a few people I think four in
total came up to me and this year's
comic-con men recognized me once take
pictures of me I want next years to be
even bigger I I don't just want it for
fame I don't want to be recognized
you know I want everyone to recognize me
I want by this time next year I want my
channel to be big enough to make an
impact on the gaming community as a
whole that's what I want that's what I
want for you guys and I believe we can
make it there you and me all of you all
of you beautiful people in there
we can actually make a difference if we
can unite the time behind a common goal
and believe that gaming is actually an
important part of our world and is going
to change society in the years to come
that's what I believe and that's what
I'm going to push and that's what I want
to be a part of and I want to make you a
part of that as well so here I am my
first step on the goal is announcing
that my 24 hour livestream not twelve
stream not 12 hour my 24 hour livestream
I've changed it back is going to be a
charity livestream for child's play
that's right we're going to make a
charity 24 hour livestream all me all
the time playing games that you all
request even Daisy if I have to even
Daisy about games for child's play and
if you don't know what child's play is
there's a link in the description for
the website where it is it's child's
play charity calm and what it is where
there are different events you can host
together to play video games or gaming
related to raise money to help sick
children in hospitals get games in their
hands to bring some joy into their life
and there are also studies to show that
gaming can help children in the healing
process but either way go to the website
and look up the information and I'll
have more information on when this
livestream is going to happen in the
very near future because it's going to
happen very soon and I want to do it
again and more I want to do more of
these big events I haven't been working
hard enough for you guys for this
channel to make it bigger and make us
grow and benefit the community because
that's what it's all about
Gaming is nothing without the community
without you guys I'm nothing but I've
been rambling for too long now so back
to the silliness let me put on my tiara
and say that thank you guys so much for
all that you've done for me really I
couldn't have done this without you
so if me acting like a goofball I'm
making laughing screaming like a little
girl will help you out in your day and
entertain you did I want to keep doing
it so thank you guys so much for
ting and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
um